President Trump plans another rally next
week in the critical battleground state
of Florida the governor's race there
reached a fever pitch last night in the
final debate between Democrat Andrew
Gilliam and Republican Ron De Santis
Elaine Quijano of our streaming network
cbsn news covering Florida's midterm
elections plain good morning good
morning it's been two decades since
Florida has elected a Democratic
governor and the race is deadlocked the
first debate was punctuated by personal
attacks including claims of corruption
and racism last night those issues came
up again and neither candidate back down
am I supposed to know every single
statement somebody makes Rhonda Santa
has offered a fiery defense his decision
to speak at events organized by an
alleged white supremacist and rejected
the notion that comments he had
previously made were racist I am NOT
going to bow down to the altar of
political correctness
I'm not calling mr. DeSantis a racist
I'm simply saying the racists believe
he's a racist he was hit hard on the
issue by Tallahassee mayor Andrew
Gilliam who faces scrutiny of his own
after an ongoing state ethics probe
revealed he received tickets to the
Broadway show Hamilton from an
undercover FBI agent investigating
Tallahassee officials I am NOT the
subject of an FBI investigation Gilliam
now says he believed his brother covered
the tickets cost by swapping them for
jay-z and Beyonce tickets we got 99
issues in Hamilton ain't one of them
DeSantis wasn't convinced why would an
undercover FBI agent posing as a
contractor give him $1,000 ticket to
Hamilton the race is seen as a
referendum on both parties as each
candidate represents a specific style of
politics Gilliam has styled himself as a
progressive and De Santis is a staunch
supporter of President Trump while
Gilliam is ahead in the latest polls and
more than a million ballots have already
been cast experts are watching the
reaction to the Hamilton revelations
among late voters the folks who are
waiting are the ones who are still
somewhat undecided a story like this can
have a real impact on them these races
get decided by such a narrow margin the
outcome of this election could set the
tone for the presidential election in
2020 President Trump himself has already
weighed in 20
about the race six times over the
weekend viana and that was a fiery
debate Elaine thank you